il était une fois h ouverture aux
cadeaux attendait chaque enfant du
village provenant d'un généreux donateur
décédé en 1957
frédéric roux liane schumaker a instauré
cette tradition il y a de cela plus d'un
siècle mais qui dispensent à gaza
voyez notre langue s'est fait confier
une mission bien spéciale les 160
cadeaux dans cette banlieue tmz
gracieuseté de monsieur chouf un cadeau
de monsieur chirac pendant le monde en
cadeau on dit ça vient de monsieur
chemin que c'est parce qu'il ya des
personnes qui pensent aussi un grand
cadeau de deux pères noël quelque chose
comme ça n'en savent rien de monsieur
chemin que c'est quelqu'un qui a laissé
l'argent pour les enfants
ouais je viens de schumacher moi j'ai
reçu des cadeaux de chou matin j'étais
jeune mon père a reçu des cadeaux du
chemin de mon grand-père reçu des
cadeaux de schumann et je sais pas ce
que j'ai eu des discussions cette année
les administrateurs de la fondation même
enfin plus d'argent donc pour appliquer
ce qui a peut être besoin d'un ennemi
cadou car c'est sa garde son mémoire en
vivant de donner des cadeaux aux jeunes
des chemins que je suis michael vient de
columbus ohio bienvenue 7 ou non pour
recherche de leur fille de l'argent
comme un homme qui travaillait dans le
même schéma que et avait pas beaucoup
d'argent
puis les jeunes adoptent un cadeau à
noël
alors monsieur schumacher acheter des
cadeaux on encore des cadeaux va qu'on
doit devenu opposant fin mai dans son
contrat lui c'était que je sois démunis
ou pas c'est un cadeau pour un enfant
ils sont vraiment je trouve ça très
intéressant comme concept mais encore
cent ans plus tard on continue à faire
ça et sans compter les pompiers qui
donnent leur talent il conduit
volontaire de la communauté du chemin
que donnent leur temps pour l'acheter
c'est cadeau le courir après ça prend du
temps ça prend de l'énergie qu'il l'a
fait avec tellement tellement de passion
et d'amour
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
intéressant
alors c'est à cette tradition concubin
prostitutes et puis on fia de devenir
des chemins qc à une petite fierté de ça
pour être une place qui continue sa
tradition